medical tourism which is a euphemism for
free trade in healthcare has allowed
patients around the world facing certain
death at home to receive life-saving
treatments abroad now with the double
whammy of Obamacare and a rapidly aging
population which will create major
healthcare shortages in the u.s. foreign
hospitals are anticipating big business
in treating Americans the growth of
American style hospitals around the
world has been geometric in the last
eight to ten years
Joseph Woodman is the CEO of patients
Beyond Borders and the author of several
guide books to the medical tourism
industry you're going to see just huge
competitive forces coming to bear on the
US healthcare system and God knows we
need it oran governments and hospitals
are staking big dollars on promotion and
infrastructure in an effort to burnish
their reputations as medical
destinations that enthusiasm was on
display last October at a medical
tourism industry conference in Florida
which drew participants from 90
countries Obamacare will be a boon for
us because access to care is going to be
much more difficult in the future it's
already difficult dr. Sam Hess is part
of a group that's working to set up a
full-service Hospital on the Caribbean
island of Saint Maarten he says
Obamacare will magnify the bureaucratic
and legal headaches that take up so much
time when he practices in the US we have
to assign more and more of our staff
just to be able to address insurance
concerns and approvals things like that
and so patients often look elsewhere who
are self-insured because they can have
the same procedure done at a much lower
cost most of the best hospitals outside
the United States tend to be better run
the payment is out-of-pocket and the
hospitals have to perform Insurance has
not infected the rest of the world and
so it's more of a buy and sell
proposition and if a hospital wants to
make money there needs to be
accountability all the way up and down
the line in other countries the prices
for major procedures run on average
about one third what US hospitals charge
I think that medical tourism will
inspire competition and competition is
good for all of us floating hospitals
that aren't tied to any particular
country such as those run by the
charitable organization Mercy Ships may
provide another disruption to our overly
regulated healthcare industry dr.
Mohammad Sayeed
is a veteran medical director for the
cruise industry with the flag of
convenience its options for you to hire
from anywhere I have doctors from Poland
France from Germany Spain you cannot do
that automatically in any country due to
immigration rules due to employment
rules due to protectionism too perfect
on the market so there are a lot of
considerations as Obamacare makes
high-quality health care more difficult
to come by many Americans will forego
their insurance coverage and simply pay
out of pocket for better and immediate
treatment abroad that's exactly what's
happened in Canada why Canadians want to
travel is because our socialized hundred
percent universal health care system is
not working keep Harrison is a nurse for
hire who cares for patients traveling
out of Canada where the average wait
time is four months for all
non-emergency procedures what ends up
happening is you got a
non-life-threatening issue becoming a
life-threatening issue and then all of a
sudden they get treatment but that can
be that can be a year so now people with
health problems they're starting to put
initiative in their own hands
Joseph Woodman says ultimately the
greatest benefit of foreign competition
will be to make US healthcare better
just like 40 years ago when the Japanese
entered the marketplace with far
superior cars at a lower price at first
they were ridiculed and they ate our
lunch and just when Detroit was
perfecting planned obsolescence they had
to start building cars that went 70
thousand miles without a lot of
maintenance and you've got those very
same people now competing for healthcare
you're gonna see a lot of health care
institutions getting off their Duff and
responding it's already began to happen